[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Amandla
it's easy give me the ball huh
hey show you river looks good
[Music]
what about that yes are you blind
no how this one I don't like it that's
the one oh no definitely not perfect
should we try oh no I think we should
call you well
oh dear okay tomorrow yes yes everyone
yes lots of tequila
lots of tequila and strippers yes yes oh
[Music]
hey hello hope you don't mind I brought
my dog huh you wanna comment it's nice
to meet you Jonas it's Yanis so what are
you from I'm from Austria Oh
Sweden let it go so what are your plans
with my daughter so what do you do for a
living
oh I'm an actor let me kiss you mind for
great for kids
I'm an actor salary I'm he's working on
me guys must have a lot of sex then huh
no no yeah oh so you're a liar how are
you 29
what do you think I'm easy 22 ish huh
Louise wired a mom come on you've lied
before I didn't have any hair you can't
trust bong-gun
I'm telling and Ryan is a magician but
already to establish himself it over
longer a little bit about what the
computer isn't I'm telling you man is
sick red flags all over the place did it
again you know he's really nice I like
him he's a keeper there he was a keeper
wasn't he now he's a leaver you just
left me
Oh dad hey guys me amanda cerny thank
you so much for watching my series kiss
and like
and commenting I literally read every
single one of them so thank you guys
concerning is growing and I love it
I want to involve you guys even more so
what I'm doing now is I'm taking
journeys get suggestion ideas that means
you just comment below any good ideas
that you have for me and if I decide to
choose your idea that will show you out
in my next journey skate youtube video
so keep the comments coming and who
knows it could be you love you guys and
I'll see you next week my Basel's